beyond the mudslides flash flooding is
also a threat for fire ravaged
communities in Northern California the
so called camp fires now 70% contained
but almost 700 people are still reported
missing at this hour at least seventy
nine people are dead Meg Oliver's in
Paradise California where the rain could
also hamper the search for the victims
may good morning gal good morning we're
standing inside a burned out home and
that rain Lonnie mentioned could be the
most significant here in the last seven
months it could help fight the fire but
it could also trigger mudslides in areas
like this wood burned out vehicles that
have already been through hell we're up
at a Lakeview circle and even Rock as
the rains moving closer to Paradise
federal search and rescue team member
Brian Ferrara says the pressure is on
the material that were that we're
dealing with it's heavily heavily you
know ash and soot and when the water
touches that it kind of turns the
sediment almost like Swale again it is
kind of urgent ahead of you did we get
through this as quick as we can are you
worried that the rain could wash away
some important DNA evidence I'm worried
about it hampering the search I'm
worried about it creating risk to the
searchers Butte sheriff Cory Honi says
the threat of mudslides would stress an
already fragile community it is the
potential of having you know dealing
with one disaster and having you know
something else pile on top of us in
nearby Chico officials are warning
evacuees in this tent city to move to
shelters because the parking lot where
they are is in a flood zone but with
tens of thousands of evacuees the
question is where should they go are you
prepared to handle the amount of people
without homes yes Kevin Hannah's with
FEMA says it's unclear if trailers will
be brought in to handle the displaced he
says many people are in hotels or have
found new places to rent adding that the
FEMA Assistance Center has been busy
processing about 1,500 people a day this
is not a normal disaster where we've
lost a residential area we've lost a
residential and the essential elements
of safety and security inside the town
of Paradise specifically
officials expect people to be in
shelters through the Christmas holiday
the other big concern is the coming rain
I talked to a man this morning whose
home was also destroyed like this one
behind me he said he would do anything
to get back there to search for his
grandfather's World War two medals
before everything gets washed away John
oh man your heart just keeps breaking
thank you so much Megan Oliver